normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government I want
to jump to the story and uh get back
into the more uh partisan politics here
this from the post-millennial breaking
home of suspect in the killing of an
elderly Jewish man at Pro Palestinian
protest has been searched by police for
those that didn't see the story otherly
Jewish man was uh I believe the
reporting is he was struck in the head
by a pro Palestinian activist fell down
hit his head and died get this first the
breaking news on the story is that
they're searching for this they're
searching this guy's house take a look
at this tweet from end wokeness an old
Jewish man was murdered by a pro
Palestine activist the medical examiner
already ruled at a homicide this is the
media coverage CNN man in California
dies after suffering head injury at pro
Israel prop Palestinian demonstrations
here's one Jewish man dies after hitting
head in altercation here's one Jewish
man dies after altercation and here's
another one Jewish man dies from injury
suffered in rally in Israel Palestine
rally incredible there was uh uh I think
it was the daily mail I tweeted this out
said uh elderly Jewish man dies after
falling and hitting head it's just
absolutely incredible so I I went
through all these stories I want to
point out something else if you go to
the Anti-Defamation leagues extremism
map the Nashville shooter is not even
listed so they all claim in the media
that the right is a big threat oh the
right wing the right wing the rightwing
a completely disorganized group of
disperate ideologies some that don't
even agree with each other the big
threat it's just random lone wolves when
there is something they call rightwing
and when you get the farle extremism
they don't even put it on the map they
don't track it and the cops don't go
after it they go after it in a certain
sense but they don't call it Terror
they'll call it just you know an
unfortunate tragedy or or something I
don't know how to explain how it feels
being banned from a country for hatred
uh or what is it racism because I called
out Islam uh not liking gay people very
much had a pride parade and then to see
the same streets filled with people like
like calling for death are you are you
still banned from the UK as far as I
know yeah and you you you you did like
this popup pointing out that Islam is
anti-lgbtq yeah so they said get out and
don't come back get out and don't come
back and then you have a bunch of people
that have immigrated there you know not
everyone obviously there are supporters
of Palestine that aren't chanting these
things of course but there were people
chanting like you know death to death to
the I don't know if I canb like and
other groups I don't know I can say on
YouTube these days but um yeah saying
these things and then none of them are
they're not even like citizens they're
not being deported and well did you see
when the guys were flying the English
flag the cops were like you got to put
that flag away it's inciting people and
then a couple guys were flying the Union
Jack which is the flag of Great Britain
not just England and they said look mate
there's more of them than us put the
flag away yeah and a lot of people were
like that's it when you can't fly the
flag of your own country in your country
because people who are not from your
country are threatening violence against
you that's that's a crazy Prospect I
think what we're seeing now with this
guy being killed and the bias look how
many how many Jewish or right-wing
protesters went to far-left events and
killed antifa guys it's it's it's not
happened what we see consistently is the
far-left engaging in acts of violence
and then they get excused by the media
the media acts like nothing happened and
no one was there and then they say oh
look because there's no reporting on
this that proves the rights the bigger
threat Steve scales I believe currently
has a colostomy bag because he was shot
wow by a far-left Bernie bro uh
supporter at at the Congressional um
baseball Rand Paul was at that same very
baseball game he had to hit the deck for
cover Rand Paul has been attacked at his
home he was attacked walking uh in DC
one time he was attacked at his home
there's the guy that you were talking
about today uh Jay in uh in
yeah Eric Daniels in uh Aaron Daniels
Aon Danel was Portland that that
happened or yeah he was shot you guys
want to know something really really
really funny when you look up the
killing of Aaron Danielson on the adl's
website it says Michael rinel an antifa
activist shot and killed a right-wing
extremist there's no reason to believe
he was an extremist at all he was just
some dude walking on the street and then
there's all angering more to the point
there's also the the kid that was killed
by the uh driver spe speically said that
he was after him because he was a trump
supporter and I'm sure that that is not
treated as a political murder because
they tried to talk it down now and and
in the 2016 election we saw so many
instances of violence against Trump
supporters I mean it it was it was just
ubiquitous but it was it wasn't covered
in the media and I U Mike cernovich went
to the White House you know at at in in
the Press beef briefing room and uh you
know he just called it out and they were
laughing at him yeah laughing at him
that was a response right but like you
know we were saying this stuff back then
already look where it is now yeah let me
let let me pull this up this from the
adl's website it says August 29 2020
leftwing Michael ryel an antifa activist
shot to death a member of a right of
right-wing extremist group during a
protest in Portland unbelievable it's
just it's factually false so it was a
guy walking down the street there was no
event the event was over and Michael
ryol who has a communist an extremist
tattoo on his neck walked up to him and
shot him twice in the chest yeah that's
or dock Crossfire right yeah um yeah and
and the way it's framed it's like well
this is an anti-fascist person doing
anti-fascist things right that's
activism yeah no this was an extremist
who sought out a person on the right to
kill but when they when they continually
lie cheat and steal and obus gate these
things now look I'm not saying you know
that the right is more or less we had
this conversation with Steph Marsh on
the culture War he says there's more
seditionists on the right I think that's
actually factually incorrect I don't
know what he means by the right and he
couldn't Define it either and he said it
wasn't helpful and I agree with him he
was it was funny cuz he was criticizing
me for saying the left and the right and
I was like well what do you say then cuz
then he said he goes look you keep
saying like the left and the right like
what does it even mean now when you talk
to the right when they say these things
I was like right there like what does it
really mean we don't know but I can tell
you that what we see in the Press always
ignores let me tell you the Summer of
Love riots was a mass death incident how
many how many deaths qualify for a mass
death incident more than three it's I
think 30 30 deaths in the Summer of Love
riots so what's the issue they have to
happen all within like 20 minutes of of
each other has to be white people
responsible then get to be so so my
point is this the riots were one thing
fueled by one thing led by people of a
shared ideology which resulted in the
death of between 24 and 36 people that's
a math that mass death incident
facilitated by the left and the issue is
exactly as as as as I describe it it is
this widespread Terror and blunt force
violence and when it reaches that level
people die now by all means be worried
and upset that there are you know uh uh
right-wing militias or whatever whatever
it is you're concerned about if someone
actually is committing violence or
threatening to do so we should stop them
what do we get we get the weird fake
kidnapping plot and then we get nothing
from Chaz chop you think the adl's
reporting on the fact that two guys
unloaded hundreds of rounds from a rifle
into a white SUV they don't do anything
I think you're right we need to be on
guard against farri extremism as well
because I think Chase geyser was saying
like if the if the pendulum were to
swing he feels I think he identified
himself he was on the show last night as
rightwing or whatever part of the
conservative movement or whatever that
if the power were to come back we need
to have a cool head like main 10 you
don't want people to go nuts on in any
direction from any and like it's this we
got to make sure that we don't
radicalize people and that we're on
guard against radicalization I really
doesn't matter what direction I don't I
forget where I read this but I someone
was talking about violence and he's and
and they said the people on the left
treat violence like a knob that you can
turn up and down and they'll turn it up
and they'll turn it down depending on
the politics of the day people on the
right treat po treat violence like an
onoff switch you're voting you're voting
now it's gunfight time and that's the
that's the that really does speak to the
character of people on the right and the
left the people on the right really do
want to work within the system and they
want to they want to they want to
believe in the system because they're
not ists the way that people on the left
are a lot of time people on the right if
they're not in organized religion they
have some kind of connection to
spirituality and stuff and so they
believe in right and wrong people on the
left don't generally believe in right
and wrong and and we had um I forget
what his name when we on the the theast
war the culture war on Friday Ste Mar so
he was talking about he mentioned
morality is meaningless yeah morality is
meaningless and so for him it's it's
it's clearly something that is is not
not black and white whereas people on
the right tend to be like it's not time
for violence it's not time for violence
kill everyone in the room look Ste
steephen Steven Marsh I think he's a
good dude in the sense that he's he's
willing to come and have a conversation
but I think he's a bad dude with all due
respect because he said he believes
children should have access to these
adult material books I wish I was there
he doesn't care he does he says morality
means nothing to me and I and I said
that's that's the problem right there
you have moral people who decide
for logical reasons some things are off
limits why well the people who are
exposed to Twisted content and and
twisted practices end up becoming very
very unhappy we're trying to reduce self
harm reduce depression maximize
productivity and happiness this is very
well recorded like you can look at uh if
porn is exposed to boys at very young
ages they tend to go for more and more
extreme things as they age to the point
where they have normalized like violence
against the gender because that's the
only thing that can get them off now and
this is very well studied anyone can
look it up and yeah it's it's totally
has to do with particularly with
exposure at Young ages where you don't
really have that decision-making skill
prefrontal cortex totally developed yet
that's actually when we were talking
about the news media trying to protect
like the the the guy who punched the
dude that died and it's like I can see
that I think that their idea is I don't
want to expose Society to the fact that
it was a a Palestinian guy or a guy that
was Pro Palestine punching a guy that
Pro because they don't want to like
twist the minds of the people but I I I
think that's because if you I've talked
about this guy Herbert maruse before on
the on the podcast he wrote a paper in
theal man he wrote the book called
m-dimensional man but he wrote a a paper
an essay called that I believe he called
it on tolerance but it was essentially
it was called repressive tolerance and
the argument that he made in it was if
it is leftwing it is acceptable to be
violent and that it is okay because
you're doing it for a good reason that's
the long and short of it it's ridiculous
and it's childlike but it's also the
type of mindset that you see coming from
the left you see it in the media when
they they don't talk about things that
the left does or they or they talk them
down or it's not that big of a deal and
yet if the right the and one of the
things that he said is you should censor
people on the right at the level of
thought if you can control people's
thoughts then they will not carry out
violence and it like I said it's called
the the uh the paper's called um on
Toleration on uh repressive tolerance
it's worth a read it's not very long but
it it really does lay out the type of
logic that leftists tend to be to be
using when they apply to everything and
and you see it in society now it's
amazing how they can create life or
death situations out of everything you
know you say it's a knob but like the
I'll notice with leftists they'll be
like you're trying to kill trans
children and that'll be like what
they're saying in their rallies and this
is why we have to have these extreme
responses and I'm like holy if you spent
like 1 second in the body of like just a
19-year-old white kid in University
experiencing their life you would become
a Nazi overnight you'd be like the
oppression I'm facing it's like nothing
it's not comparable you have the
corporations the banks the government
the media all these people on your side
and you still think it's a life or death
oppression situation imagine having none
of that in in uh in the documentary
infringed we're going to keep plugging
it because we want you to watch it you
talk to a guy in Berkeley you're going
around asking people at Berkeley do they
want to ban guns and then you finally
meet one guy who's like no and then he
says he's a gay Republican and then
you're like do you feel safe and he's
like well you know yeah kind of not
really yeah I got some questions about
infringed maybe you guys can answer them
for me uh since you did it how many guns
did you fire over the course of the
shooting oh that's a funny word shooting
isn't that a weird metaphor filing the
shoot well shooting round count I I
can't the most guns would have been theg
asut come ranch right yeah yeah C Ranch
what what sounds intriguing tell me more
that's one hell of a tangent
Lauren um I guess the shooting range
that Brandon and Cody go and shoot at
was actually like a NASA training
facility or something and they it's not
it's not at the range it's like it's
close by they've got like a yeah I don't
know if this secret is it supposed to be
secret I don't know I'm so sorry if I no
I did publish a bit of that yeah this is
Brandon Herrera and Cody Wilson they
assume that the astronauts were up to no
good while they were there so they call
it that oh that's funny I see so how
many oh total weapons do you think you
you sampled over there the or do I mean
let's talk about it well let we'll say
that one for only I'd at least a couple
dozen maybe more 30 40 no I wasn't that
well I was shooting in Canada as well
and then we were shooting with STA and
uh oh yeah you're probably right
probably like a couple dozen yeah we
shot like maybe four or five in Virginia
and then at the at the ranch in San
Antonio like maybe 10 really I'm hyping
things up in my head woman moment they
were high caliber guns as well it was
very there was an anti-aircraft weapon
that we fired which was really was that
is 50 BMG I think it's uh there's only
like eight of them in existence they to
shoot helicopters but you can hold them
standing yeah that was I don't know what
was that I think uh uh Brandon had it it
was a shoulder I I don't know about guns
it was bu like a Bullpup 50 BMG that he
had mounted on his shoulder and was
firing yeah yeah we both got to shoot
that that was like really crazy and also
Hitler's Buzz saw Hitler's Buzz saw 42
was very popular amongst
the and then it like gave me this really
bad rash on my arm there was a p's
hickey Hitler's hickey is what we call
that was the mg42 the hickey you guys
called it the hickey that's the mg42 so
why do they call it the Hitler's Buzz is
that cuz the dude's in super fast so
it's the same gun that that the Nazis
used in World War II uh it was just a
different round back then so now it's
it's been changed to a Nato round um but
yeah you know it's the same gun
otherwise this is when super rapid fire
like in Band of Brothers where they're
like attacking Machine Gun Nest like
that's the gun the mg is the one it's
like a massage your whole body is like
shaking it's bizarre I will just say
real quick you can watch the full
documentary on
timcast.net
just as long as you know we got an add
up on Twitter I put up I put up a clip a
trailer for it I put $50,000 behind it
it's not just about getting people to
watch a documentary Making getting new
memberships making more documentaries
the ads them themselves are activism if
we can make a lot of money off this
documentary and then put out
advertisements that effectively advocate
for gun rights and normalize gun safety
and gun culture we are winning the
culture War so we want to do more of
this we got a whole bunch more plans so
definitely check out the documentary and
become a member don't miss it thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net